Emotional intelligence refers to how well
we handle ourselves and our relationships,
the 4 domains.
Self-awareness, knowing what we’re feeling,
why we’re feeling it, which is a basis of,
for example, good intuition, good decision-making.
Also, it’s a moral compass.
Say, in part, is self-management, which means
handling your distressing emotions in effective
ways so that they don’t cripple you, they
don’t get in the way of what you’re doing,
and yet, attuning them… to them when you
need to so that you learn what you must.
Every emotion has a function.
Also, [marshalling] positive emotions, getting
ourselves, you know, involved, enthused about
what we’re doing, aligning our actions with
our passions.
The third is empathy, knowing what someone
else is feeling.
And the fourth is putting that altogether
in skilled relationship.
So that’s what I mean by emotional intelligence.
There’re many definitions out there.
The part of the brain, it turns out, that
supports emotional and social intelligence
is actually the last circuitry of the brain
to become anatomically mature.
And because the neuroplasticity of the brain
shapes itself according to repeated experiences,
so my argument is, hey, we should be teaching
kids regularly overtime, in a systematic way,
self-awareness, self-management, empathy,
and social skill.
In fact, there, now, enough programs and they’ve
been around enough in schools that they’re
about to publish a huge meta analysis, looking
at hundreds of schools and kids that had the
program versus those that don’t.
Guess what?
All anti-social behavior, you know, disruption
in class, find that… it goes down 10%.
Pro-social behavior, liking school, well-behave,
up 10%.
Academic achievement scores, up 11%.
So it really pays.
Executive function, which is mediated by the
prefrontal lobe, both helps you manage your
emotions and helps you pay attention.
So as kids learn these skills, they also learn
learning… basic learning skills.
I think that the fact that that was an argument
was one thing that caught people’s attention.
Then, there was a little chapter on… called
managing with heart, which argued that leaders
who were sons of a bitch were actually defeating
the company’s own mission.
And I think that made a lot of people happy
because they work for people like that.
I don’t know…
Some people gave it to other people because
they thought they needed help in this domain.
I’m sure there’re a zillion reasons why
people like the book.
I hope more.
I know IQ has been going up for a hundred
years as children encounter more sophisticated
cognitive environment as they grow.
I don’t know that we’re becoming more
emotionally intelligent.
I like to hope we would but I think that the
number of intergroup wars going on, the intergroup
hatred going on, the, you know, levels of
familial abuse, in other words, indicators
of emotions out of control in dangerous ways
don’t look that great, which is why I’m
a very strong proponent of getting these social,
emotional learning programs in every school
worldwide.
Well, I get asked that question in a different
way, which is, are women more emotionally
intelligent than men?
And you have to remember that emotion intelligence
is a range of abilities, self-awareness, emotional
self-management, empathy, social skills.
Women tend to be better than men on average
at empathy, particularly emotional empathy,
sensing in the moment how the other person
is feeling and also, at social skills, at
keeping things feeling good between people
in a group.
Men, on the other hand, tend to be better
on average at self-confidence, particularly
in group, and at managing distressing emotions.
But what’s very interesting is if you look
at leaders who were in the top 10%, there’s
no difference between the men and the women
on any of those variables.
In other words, you have a whole human being.
So I would say that on average, there probably
are differences men and women in this domain
of ability.
But as people develop their skills, as people
become more effective, they pick up strengths
in areas that they need.
Well, I think that emotional intelligence
as a universal but it looks different in different
places.
You know, Japan has a very rigid set of rules
of social interaction, lots of subtleties.
Americans typically blender in to the Japanese
system, don’t get what’s going on.
And, you know, it’s embarrassing but they
wouldn’t recognize, necessarily, emotional
intelligence in Japanese setting.
Brazil is a very different culture.
It’s very outgoing, you know, kind of like
an Italian culture.
And so, it will look different there but I
think the fundamentals are the same.